[Music]
fun is it to have three guys we're gonna
dig down the field you can choose from
just three I think is more than that I
mean it's around about town of this
offense is full of it you said it it's
fun it's fun to be a part of it it's fun
to be the quarterback of this group to
be able to go out there and lead these
guys the offensive line the way they
played the receivers making plays the
backs obviously it's just great to be a
part of this group dak Prescott the
Cowboys quarterback 405 passing yards
four touchdown passes tying a
career-high 25 of 32 on a day when Zeke
had only 53 yards on 13 carries dak
Prescott before our eyes continuing what
he did last year becoming a franchise
quarterback and has that new offense to
operate now is it that the Giants
defense isn't any good I mean we're
gonna find out over time whether or not
this can be replicated but I liked what
I saw yesterday from back Prescott I did
too I mean it was aggressive the the
passing offense and and really that what
really showed itself not only is dak
Prescott on his football game but you
know there's three legitimate weapons on
the outside for the Dallas Cowboys let
alone to a tight end in in Blake jar win
who adds a nice little wrinkle to that
offense along with Jason Witten but when
you look at it and go ooh
Mikel gallop and Amari Cooper you leave
them one-on-one outside they can run by
just about anybody in football and then
Randall Cobb and Randall Cobb looked
really nice on the inside of that
offense kind of work in the middle of
the field doing things like that so
really impressed with what I saw from
Kellen Moore looked like there was a few
more ideas in the offense and we know
it's only a matter of time before that
running game gets going the uniforms are
the same is what we've always seen but
just watching the clips on NBCSN there
is a palpable difference definitely
right yes there's a belief there that
they think they're a Superbowl team they
look like a Super Bowl team but just
like the quick the quick play-action oh
yes there's motion pieces are moving
differently than what we're used it's
not stagnant it's not just oh this is
what we do and we're the cowboys and
we're talented and we're just gonna beat
you cuz we're we got better players than
you know you know that's fine you can
get away with that against the lower
class of the
NFL the point is the Cowboys won the
Super Bowl and now they're starting to
looks like they're gonna give their
offensive schematic advantage against
some of these better teams and it was a
very encouraging start now I will say
this the Giants secondary was certainly
the weakness of their football team you
know I mean if you ask most people who's
in the secondary for the Giants they'd
go I'm not sure and I have Landon
Collins oh yeah right exactly jinora's
Jenkins is the only holdover you know
and they got some other issues at other
positions and they were mismatched
severely yesterday Jerry Jones the owner
of the Cowboys said after the game on
Dax contract status we'll get it done
yeah it would probably be fair to say
it'll be done on an immanent basis
imminent without being real clear bright
line it's not done what's imminent well
days days or something like that god I
love Jerry Jones I did say here's the
thing there was a report from ESPN
yesterday that Dax in no hurry to do a
deal he's making a bunch of money off
the field and endorsements yeah because
he's the Cowboys quarterback that's the
chicken and the egg proposition here
right because he's making all that money
off the field the Cowboys wanted to take
less because he's the quarterback of the
Cowboys where he can make all that money
off the field they need to work this out
though you don't want to wait until
Patrick mahomes signs his contract no
before you get dak Prescott son because
mahomes is gonna set the new bar and
then Prescott will come in behind it and
it's gonna be a lot higher than where
Prescott is currently looking they need
to forget about here's the problem Chris
and I know this for a fact yeah that one
year left on back Prescott's deal at two
million dollars it makes it so hard to
do a contract because if you give him
we've talked about the Jimmy Garoppolo
deal right that's a fair deal but it
drives up that new money average 234
million and it looks like it's too much
yeah they just need to say forget it
what point about we're doing the deal
that works right and we're gonna move
he's our guide let's go let's move
forward why should he be punished for
being a fourth round watch should he be
punished for anything for winning the
job and becoming a starting quarterback
and taking the block a once he started
every game he started more games than
Jared Goff more games than Carson Wentz
he's never missed a game due to injury
he's never been benched has ever even
been a discussion of it yeah 49 games 49
starts it's not his fault he was a
fourth round pick
call it a steal be happy about it pay
the
he's a beast and they better watch out
because they're gonna play another team
next week we're oh they let up a few big
plays in the passing game - they got the
Washington Redskins next week so yeah I
mean you know he starts to string
together big game after a big game after
a big game and we start sitting here
going whoa
this cowboy offenses running through dak
Prescott this year he's gonna start
saying uh Russell money Russell Wilson
money looks good to me that looks good
to me and that can that could change
things
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports